avant de commencer laissez-moi vous
informer que cette vidéo c'est la vidéo
d'aujourd'hui est sponsorisé par une
marque qui nous suit depuis plusieurs
années sur plusieurs formats des armées
je parle évidemment du vpn dpp n 9 et n
vous connaissez déjà sans doute sauvé
peine parce que ça fait plusieurs vidéos
maintenant qui travaillent avec nous
qu'ils soutiennent de travail et puis
aussi parce que on l'entend déjà lors du
big bang c'est un très vieux vpn
européenne dans le décor du cosmos on
entend
mais vous le connaissez aussi et surtout
parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est simplement le
plus rapide du marché le plus simple
d'utilisation avec sa connexion
automatique qui permet une protection
sans aucune intervention mais du coup
loïc ça sert à quoi notre pm ba devait
leur répondre déjà à surfer avec plus de
sécurité quand vous êtes sur un wifi
publics par exemple dans un bar à la
bibliothèque lors d'un voyage mais aussi
pour contourner les restrictions pour
regarder des programmes étrangers ou des
programmes français depuis l'étranger et
pourquoi pas pour accéder à des jeux
vidéo qui sera indisponible dans le pays
dans lequel vous vous trouvez
actuellement et oui avec north bay peine
vous pouvez continuer de regarder vos
séries de jouer à vos jeux vidéo même
pendant vos vacances à l'étranger ça
marche aussi pour le sport north bay pen
ne fait pas de sport à votre place par
contre donc vous habitez en france mais
vous voulez regarder des événements
sportifs qui sont seulement 10 points en
belgique avec normes et pnc possible
c'est utile si vous cherchez un vpn
c'est sûrement norvégienne qui vous faut
vous pouvez passer par mounir qui est
dans la description pour bénéficier
d'une belle offre actuelle qui fait
plaisir merci non européennes c'est
incroyable d'être le premier à vous
parler d'eux en plus j'en suis très fier
voilà fabien toujours premiers sur le
coup
oui comme bienvenue dans cette vidéo que
j'ai un peu de mal à définir en fait on
va mélanger deux choses on va mélanger
la découverte du travail de deux
souffleurs de verre avec la découverte
de la surcharge cognitive qui si elle
est très très hot empêcherait peut-être
de mentir ou en tout cas nous ferait
accéder à un espèce de sérum de vérité
au même niveau ou plus fort là alors
tout ça ça se passe principalement grâce
à just glacé it ce sont deux personnes
mail et colin qui font des choses
incroyables que vous êtes en train de
voir là sur instagram ils ont aussi un
tick tock d'ailleurs on va apprendre à
faire ce genre de choses jean transpire
des martys senti tellement dangereux et
ça commence maintenant
[Musique]
william d'accès bonne nous sommes donc
avec maël et colin et on va leur
apprendre à souffler le berre exactement
on travaille nous avec un chalumeau qui
est spécial saint jalme oswald rire avec
ce genre de chalumeau là on monte je
serai à 1502 et on travaille du coup à
partir de baguettes de verre qu'on va
faire fondre directement dans la flotte
ça brûle une pizza ça sans heurts au
fond je pense que la chose mais elle m'a
envoyé un message où elle m'a dit j'ai
découvert à sérum de vérité et c'est mon
matériel j'ai une proposition de
recommencer à fonctionner ouais je vois
la personne assise sur un besoin d'une
information qu'elle te donne médaille à
celui du lycée qui lui fait des gouttes
de bêtes sur le feu rouge elle va tout
vous dire
et ça a priori ça viendrait et c'est
assez logique quand on y réfléchit de la
surcharge cognitive qui est que pour
mentir il faut avoir accès à un
raisonnement très complexe et du cerveau
et de la créativité et que là ça doit
demander une telle concentration qu'en
fait tu dois t'en surcharge cognitive et
donc tu as pu le loisir de mentir et
peut-être même ça peut-être pas le
loisir de pas répondre en fait je crois
que la meilleure manière de le voir se
sait que tu en fasses directement et que
moi je te poses des questions que j'ai
préparé sur sur mon téléphone que mérite
la gâcher
c'est pas mal
[Musique]
william t'es pas assez près mais c'est
parfois une photo je voudrais que tu
sois bien près c'est vraiment avec mais
entre nous deux sa mort est perforé le
froc du coup elle est déjà préchauffer
le hockey
commence et où oui j'ai pris sa main
gauche oui comme ça
par dessus je transpire s'aggrave faut
que je puisse tourner ok c'est bon il va
la technique pour une fois que tu va
déposer ton père comme ça tu vas venir
du coup chaufferie la baguette levé je
viens poser dessus voilà est en fait un
moment où il ya contact là je tombe tu
viens de tourner mais très doucement et
vers l'avant d'accord donc la main
droite bouge pas elle tente maintenant
envoie en route c'est comme un stylo
pour stocker et ça va s'entourer dessus
vous allez faire face à des enfants
depuis combien d'années avec margot des
morts je suis pas content que rien mais
j'ai bien dis moi tu connais la date où
il va donc bientôt sept ans ça fait ça
c'est un parapheur ça va tomber sur la
table et notre
geste choquant par des lunes a pour but
de séparer tu va lever comme ça et c'est
sur cette position là tu es lui faut
jamais qui touche la femme
[Musique]
s'est gaussé de
chauffe ouais ouais ok je vais enlever
mes lunettes parce que ça me stresse ok
c'est quoi ta motivation principale pour
faire des vidéos là tous les mois
payer mes employés c'est pas du tout la
bonne réponse
c'est la passion des vidéos y ait un
temps qu'on est sur un sujet chaud c'est
quoi ta pyrope ton père clients cette
équipe je dois citer de nom faux - citer
un nom c'est une que j'ai fini par ne
jamais faire ces colis encore
c'est un client que je connais oui c'est
un client qui vend des matelas ah non
c'est suite au dénouement pas forcément
parce qu'ils veulent vraiment ils
veulent vraiment m'envoyer un matelas et
j'en veux pas parce que j'en ai déjà et
je veux pas d'autre matelas peu importe
combien youtuber questions étaient les
questions arabes y sont assez proches
pour 20000 euros oui je mets ma main
donc tu fais tu fais une opé make-up
mais genre sérieuse
tu fais une manie grouting pour 20000
euros sur sa chaîne youtube en
expliquant que c'est un gage non non
c'est pas un gage c'est un match sérieux
1er degré près mme daigle oui bah oui 22
euros
j'ai mal aux bras c'est terrible je m'en
rapproche tu tiens quand on a dormi
ensemble en tanzanie dans le même lit
j'espérais quelque chose ou pas oui
j'espérais ce que j'ai eus fabien ça me
voir me laver dans un lavabo un maudit
lui et c'est un peu moi je fais ma
bourhim vous pourrez nous les sauver
après ou pas alors que tu vas forcément
c'est vrai mais elle est belle
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi ton plus grand rêve nous
visiter tous les pays du monde et la
plus belle femme du monde mario
évidemment
ça va tu m'a posé la question je t'ai
pas trop concentré
côté oui ça va être de venir m
sila est ce que tu as déjà menti depuis
le début la wii alors à quelques
questions je ne peux pas te dire sinon
j'ai eu mon mensonge ne sert plus à rien
merci
c'était de la sueur de stress
tu comptes faire youtube total ait ce
genre dans dix ans si le projet date
elle était encore sur la plateforme moi
je m'amuse bien que tu es au taquet
l'adaptateur là je suis totalement
concentré et si youtube ferme par
exemple tu ferais quoi cela on peut la
merde carrément n'a pas de plan b si je
ferai des documentaires ttc red band à
la télé du coup par exemple fait ça
comment cette boule en mémoire du petit
point commun
oui oui ouais mais
on voit qu'on n'est plus malléable si ça
va péter encore la main
quand tu prends cela comme ça non
vraiment ça c'est très agréable d'avoir
cette information le des risques si j'ai
mal au dos vidic s'est fait tellement
stressée et donc en fait tu viens coupé
c'est la flamme qui va couper le fil de
la wii donc je laisse tomber posent
mutuellement la l'offrir margot ouais on
voit le chiffre de moi un mouton ne
sommes là que je m'en sors bien fabien
un orage content pour toi en plus je
suis très heureux que tu trouves que tu
t'en sors bien moi j'ai assez de points
là ça me serait sinon rebondir au
cerveau on a envie de le garder comme ça
c'est très bon et là je fais quoi je
l'en font cela
amélie vous fait peur là totalement
santé par la scène
là c'est bon tu perds tu enfonces
mahoudeaux et je suis tellement c'est
terrible c'est un état de stress
permanent terrible
c'est indescriptible ce par contre c'est
si satisfaisant quand tu vois que tu
arrives là je veux par contre je suis
une éponge mars et l'état et de la santé
par contre et a mobilisé 100 % pendant
attention mon match et tu te dit vas-y
je vais le trick et je vais répondre
très vite et après tu es concentré mais
je réfléchis encore donc tu continues à
parler et des trucs que tu devrais pas
être
incroyable faute c'est le cas c'est
dommage qu'on ait pas de temps pour moi
parce que j'habite
à des shows des fous en plus il est 15
heures près a dit moi j'ai mis trois
minutes t'inquiète pas tu vas réussir on
earth est directe alors faites moi voir
cette vilaine dans
pour montrer aux viewer que c'est bien
du vrai faux ce que tu veux mettre la
main dedans s'il te plaît alors moi je
peux pas parce que vraiment j'ai les
mains pleines donc si tu peux le faire
toi en
confiant à non attends j'allais oublier
il ya le début où ça va péter à free
c'est frais c'est pourquoi t'en parle
choisissez une couleur de base et une
couleurs de prendre allez on va prendre
du genre ok donc ok là j'ai retenu il
fallait un truc dans chaque mois c'est
ça peut y aller tu commences à
préchauffer donc tu te mets à peu près
ici ok moi je transpire match plein
débat j'ai les mains bien qu'elle
transpire comme des pieds c'est
incroyable c'est incroyable ça chauffe
ça va péter bien sûr ça va changer de
couleur sa mère est ce que tu pourrais
nous raconter stopper le moment le plus
mal et lente a vécu sur sanne sur scène
c'est quand un mec a sorti son organe
sexuel choix c'est vrai oui casino de
châtelaillon en 2008 mais pour mais
pourquoi on veut des détails c'était mon
premier numéro de seine et
ça va
monter puis j'ai dit on va faire un tour
ensemble je me retourne vers le public
pourra dire un truc et le mec je me
retourne il avait sorti son truc en dix
ans les magiciens et peut être par
grandir ma baguette et moi j'ai dit
belge fait de la magie pas du miracle
mauvais sens oui c'est vrai trophée sens
il avait
ce que stoppait tu peux nous vous
réciter l'alphabet à l'envers oui bien
sûr z y xwb vitesse circulaient aux nma
lequel j ai fait des cbr tu peux le
faire beaucoup plus lentement cet accès
directs ide eric b l'itc faire q p o n
mlk jimmy page fb side est décédé dcb à
bobigny en coton à prendre tu tires tu
vas rester collé à droite à un truc
à cause de qui le dote seven qui pose
des questions de merde ou non elle est
belle à la sévérité donc là on coupe le
rush et ont commencé
puisque c'est michel cymes qui a écrit
tous livrés et toi t'as juste me tomber
dessus non j'ai beaucoup écrit j'ai
beaucoup beaucoup écrit est ce que tu
préfères faire un spectacle entièrement
nue ou bien mourir dans d'atroces
souffrances spectacle entièrement nue et
du coup c'est prévu pour quand bah
écoute le jour où j'aurai pas le choix
c'est à dire qu vraiment si je fais pas
le spectacle tout nu je risque de mourir
dans d'atroces souffrances tout va bien
j'ai une énigme pour toi oui il va
falloir se reconcentrer départ oui si
pierre a trois enfants oui paul sept ans
oui jacques douzans oui et gertrude 32
ans combien jacques at-il de chance
d'aller au parc d'attraction avec
quelqu'un mais quelqu'un de sexe
masculin et féminin sachant qu'il ne
peut y aller qu'avec deux personnes ne
doit pas forcément avec ses enfants déjà
que c'est l'un des enfants
il veut même pas réflexion non j'étais
derrière ces des enfants de pierre
pierre il n'a pas d'enfant s'il tient il
à prendre car je le connais pierre reid
pour jacques et gertrude là je sais pas
ce que je fais je fais des cas très
moderne jacky veut aller au parc
d'attractions mais il ne peut y aller
qu'avec un garçon et une fille vous
qu'ils sont quatre comme ils attendirent
et avec un garçon et c'est franchement
il est trop jeune pour moi les
attractions n'y a pas besoin d'y aller
il a bien travaillé à l'école je veux
voir ses notes et après je déciderai
c'est quoi le le pire fit sur ta chaine
certainement apprécié d'oxygène avec qui
n'ont cessé de jouer avec des ténors
c'est de la fesci ces
noms ils étaient six chiens
dans la vidéo on va cibler des bips
aurait cité les 50 premières décimales
de pi ca ou trois en en sautant une
surcote
4on ans aucune sur 2,9 de 6,5 il
occupait j'ai déjà pas le faire à jean
alors ces petits coups c'est pas là en
mettant boury que j'étais en faire une
sur deux enfin sur une sur deux trois
quatre en fait je les chouchouter dans
ma tête les autres 8 bat si tu veux mais
nous on entendra une tour de 4 5 7
qui n'en a récité que devant en fait si
on perd c'est que le sang bleu lointier
regarde je te juger ce sens qu'elle
jugeait en turquie mais jusqu'à ce que
tu fais exactement
excusez moi d'être un professionnel un
moment donné
il vous suffit bouge peu il répond
qu'est-ce qui réfléchit sans réfléchir
un airois [ __ ] elle même bravo trop
fort qu'est-ce qu'on peut écraser je
marque une très grosse pause
d'hier la région ce qu'il va donner à
cette prochaine énigmes jeux leur fondre
fabien je grossis et pourtant je ne
prends pas de toit qui suit une ombre
non ça marche
bleu c'est la femme saab et dessins bd
ascension vers le ton pas vers toi je te
trouvais trop en confiance je réchauffe
stappert l'attention échanges leblanc
échange le bluff bien mais ici oui c'est
un
petit peu moi c'est vraiment des points
des points très quoi tu connais très
bien dépendre d'un tir de bombe pourquoi
pas baiana que j'ai merdé mais c'est un
effet coin voilà c'est exactement ce que
je voulais faire j'avais exactement ça
précisément dans ma tête c'est fini
battus ouvre la bouche et u en font
c'est bien cher effectivement je
j'enfonce
sursis en plus je m'étais dit allez me
concentre mentalement je sais faire
baisser le stress je pus mon frère c'est
altedia c'est je pense que c'est la
flamme qui est trop chaude en fait et
c'est ça qui nous fait transpirer n'ont
vraiment pas important c'est pas faux
devant un mail à le côté saturation de
la charge cognitive je les ai sentis de
ouf car en fait il ya des fois je
t'écoute ait pu et je t'écoute est plus
je faisais juste en sorte d'avoir l'air
digne et que rien ne peut prendre des
bruits
et bizarrement comme quoi dans le
cerveau si le processus décisionnel il
ya un truc qui perd c'est tout c'était
mail parce que en fait intérieurement du
coup je prête à maël la plus grande
ancienneté dans ce travail là et du coup
si elle disait un truc pour moi c'est
que y avait urgence thual envoyé une
info en mode la manga si tu fais pas ça
tu peux mourir et donc que qui se passe
et je tends porte des tueurs pour pas
être en finale c'est incroyable oh mon
dieu bravo bravo moi quand est-ce qu'on
voit le résultat alors tu crois que
c'est déjà bon ah ouais trop combien de
refroidir
[Musique]
alors ça c'est le tiens ça dans chaque
un point celui de soutien je fais pas
voir alors chacun regarde et cash avec
ça moi
je vais gagner moi je suis désolé tu as
fait du colis dans fait tatami nico vide
bat donc ces styles je pense que c'est
un truc que tu pourrais dernier ça va
péter à comment il est il est vrai alors
il est pas on vous aime bien les effets
moi que ça fait quand elles ont fondu la
regarde franchement j'aime bien moi je
préfère le bien comme virginie tu dois
bien là qu'elle est appréciée attention
parce que tu vas en vexin emmené au
dehors donc dis pas que c'est moche
c'est pas là orange ma préférée c'est la
chose je cocasse
c'est toi fanny vient comme ça tu vas
nous dire laquelle et a préféré mais on
sait déjà on sait détaille à aucun
suspense ya aucun suspense en france n
ya aucun suspense elle a dit bah
évidemment
tout tout mais moi j'ai voulu faire le
vide
imed ben oui c'est bien original ça veut
dire beau nom
[Rires]
de mercy d'autres d'avoir participé à
cette expérience de surcharge cognitive
et en même temps et surtout de travail
du verre quoi c'était d'un green on va
te faire ça si vous est ce que tu savais
ce que tu venais faire aujourd'hui non
comme j'avais décidé de ne le dis pas
donc moi j'arrive je fais des trucs cool
on se revoit bientôt pour clés de troyes
ouais elle était fait ça je sais
pourquoi je n'ai pu bien préparé une
spoil rien de toute façon cette vidéo
sera désassortis quant au tournage sera
fini
alors vous pouvez évidemment retrouver
dans la description tous les liens vers
jazz classique tu vois le lien de leur
instagram de leurs tik tok et de la
boutique y aura aussi le lien vers la
chaîne youtube de doc seven et puis moi
je vais du coup créer une boutique et un
business pour que vous puissiez vous
procurer ces nouvelles oeuvres j'arrête
youtube et je me lance dans la
confection de petite merde oui un peu
raté et je me dis qu'on dirait que c'est
de l'art contemporain merci qui ne doit
pas regarder la vidéo ici vous en
propose deux autres qui n'ont rien à
voir mais qui sont toutes les deux avec
doc seven vous pouvez vous abonner
activer la cloche une vie art dans les
commentaires ce que vous en avez pensé
si vous êtes allé voir un peu le travail
de jazz faiblesse it sur les réseaux
qu'est ce que vous en pensez ce que vous
avez qui fait ces espèces de galaxies
juste incroyable prenez soin de vous
prenez juin rené juin juillet en repos
histoire de vous calmer après cette
grosse année à très bientôt ciao